welcome to the NewsHour Ukrainian troops
have encircled the russian-controlled
supply Hub of liman in the Donetsk
region so that comes a day after
President Putin declared four Eastern
regions including Donetsk part of Russia
the head of the russian-backed
administration indonesque said on Friday
Lehman was partly encircled by the
Ukrainian Army
we have three correspondents covering
the latest developments Muhammad Val is
in Moscow Abdul Hamid is in zapparicha
and we have Charles Stratford live for
us in sloviansk in the Donetsk region
let's go to Charles first so Charles
what are you hearing about the
encirclement of liman and what's
happening there
yeah these are some very significant
lines coming from the Ukrainian military
they saying that they have surrounded
the Strategic town of Lee man a town
that fell under the control of the
Russians after Fierce fighting in May it
is a huge strategic importance because
it is a railway Hub and a supply line
two Russian forces across this region of
course
this news if indeed it is true is
significant because it is part of what
has been a very successful
counter-offensive in the last couple of
weeks by Ukrainian forces pushing south
from kharkiv and retaking control of
thousands of square kilometers of
territory
we are hearing also according to the
ukrainians that they believe that up to
5 500 Russian troops could be trapped
inside liman and it was the presidential
advisor president zielinski the
Ukrainian presidential advisor Michael
has tweeted that Moscow should appeal to
Kiev
um if they wanted them to release those
soldiers if not one can only presume the
implication is is that they will be
taken prisoner we understand that a lot
of these men could well be Russian
Special Forces of course it's mostly
possible to verify any of this news at
the moment it's very very difficult for
the media to get any kind of access even
close to Lee man at the moment and the
surrounding Villages of Lee man as well
because this operation isn't just uh
concentrated on the city itself there
are a number of villages both to the
North and the South that we understand
the military operation is ongoing inside
these Villages and settlements one of
the big reasons again why this is
important news is that from Le man it
means that Ukrainian forces can
potentially push Northeast towards
lugansk which we know they pretty much
don't control any of it there are
pockets of lugansko blast that they have
been fighting to retake over the last
couple of months and it also means that
they can push down from Liam and
potentially Southeast towards what is
increasingly becoming the besieged city
of bakmut where there is an ongoing
heavy shelling in that City over the
last few weeks and we understand at
least 20 000 people civilians still in
that City so yeah if indeed this is true
This is highly significant in terms of
military strategy and a military success
for the Ukrainian Army right Charles
you'll keep us across the story thank
you so much Charles Stratford for that
update let's not bring in Hameed she's
joining us from zapparicha and there are
reports that the director general of the
nuclear plant uh where you are in
zapparicha has been detained by Russian
forces tell us what you're hearing
yes indeed we actually spoke to the
energy which is the company Ukrainian
company that is in charge of the
zeparija plant and we talked to the
Civil Administration here and they both
say that basically the director of the
plant was driving yesterday from there
to the city of anergonda which is on the
terror the part of Jaipur region claimed
by Russia when a Russian Patrol stopped
him got him out of the car blindfolded
him and they at this stage they don't
know where he is nor do they know what's
the fate of the Ukrainian employees who
have been working at that factory even
though the Russians had seized it in the
very beginning of the war while these
employees had stayed there to make sure
of this the safety of that nuclear plant
they are the ones who actually shut down
all six reactors one after the other
they're the ones who re-hook that plant
to the electrical grid so there is no
news of that and there's also no news of
the two Experts of the atom
International Atomic agency who had
remained behind after a delegation had
visited it about a month ago now I don't
know if they pulled out or not we have
no information about that at this stage
but I have to say you get an you really
get the feeling that ever since
President Vladimir Putin made that
announcement Russia is taking control of
that part of Zappa region that it's that
it that it claims it is not very far
from where we're standing now this is a
road where usually at this time of the
day you would see civilians coming out
of that part of Zappa regia region some
of them coming from the Herson region we
are told by Authority that since
midnight no one has been able to come
through the Russians wouldn't let them
through they now need a special
permission to be able to cross into
Ukrainian side
um that's very similar to what happened
actually in Crimea after Russia nexted
back in
2014 so as we understand it we spoke to
some of those who managed to come out at
the last minute really
um now there's need of that special
permit and they were told by the Russian
soldiers at that last checkpoint that
this is now going to be considered an
international border okay thank you so
much reporting from zapparicha well
let's find out what the Russians are
saying about all of this and cross over
to Moscow Muhammad Val joining us from
there so it's almost 24 hours Muhammad
since President Putin declared those
four regions in Ukraine as part of
Russia what are you hearing from your
rent and what's the mood like in Moscow
thank you
well during the mood is a mood of
satisfaction with what President Putin
has decreed and had signed yesterday in
the streets people were stopping when we
were doing our live shots from the
streets uh congratulating themselves and
talking in good words about what Putin
has decided we understand of course that
not Russians are you know for this war
or maybe for this annexation but at
least in the streets the visibility is
for those who are waving National
Russian flags and showing that they are
happy with the decision not many
statements have come out since that big
celebration yesterday and that signing
but we know that the deputy chairman of
the uh of the uh National the Russian
Federation Council of security Dimitri
met viedev on his account on East on
telegram he criticized the statements he
criticized actually the application by
president zielinski for the uh for
joining NATO and he said that instead of
leading to Solutions this is going to
speed up
towards the World War World War III he
said that that's that's not a good
decision uh he also criticized Ian
stoltenberg for his statements in which
he said that if Ukraine stops fighting
it means the end of Ukraine he said
instead of that if Ukraine continues to
fight it will mean the death of many
more ukrainians so Russians are very
firm in their stance
towards what they have decided and they
are adamant that they will they were not
only going to defend the land that they
are next but they are also going to
complete the Liberation in their terms
of the rest of those territories thank
you so much Muhammad Val reporting from
Moscow